later today for a man who was shot by a
police officer inside his own apartment
in Dallas
both of John was killed last week by an
off-duty police officer her name is
Amber Geiger protestors condemned the
shooting at a Dallas City Council
meeting yesterday and they are demanding
justice for John Omar Villafranca is in
Dallas where he spoke with John's family
in their first sit-down interview
together
Omar good morning Gail good morning
John's family says they don't think
Dallas police officer amber Geiger is
telling the whole story about what
happened at this apartment complex and a
week after he was killed they still
don't know why misson loss as to what
one week after losing their son both
them Allison and Bertram Jean still
aren't satisfied with the details
surrounding his death I still don't have
a conclusive what happened
is that just keeping you up but that's
the pain that's what causes the pain
off-duty police officer Amber Geiger is
accused of killing the 26 year old last
Thursday the family says they don't
believe the officers version of events
one of the things I would like is what
ambit's just completed Geiger told
investigators that she went to what she
thought was her third-floor apartment
instead the 30 year old went to John's
fourth floor apartment directly above
hers Geiger says the door was ajar and
inside notice the apartment interior was
nearly completely dark Alisa is both I'm
sister to hear that you know his door
was open he would never and have the
lights off he would never do that he was
like me I don't like the dark
believing John to be a burglar Geiger
says after she gave verbal commands that
were ignored she fired her handgun twice
hitting him once in the torso
it wasn't until Geiger turned on the
lights and called 911 realized she was
at the wrong apartment
the family says Jean placed a red carpet
in front of his door to distinguish his
apartment from others he made sure to
let everyone know this is
is my red carpet Jean grew up in st.
Lucia
but his brother Brandt says that he was
well aware of racial tensions in America
he said to me as a black man and um in
Dallas
you don't walk with your hands in your
pockets just so you don't get any
profiling Geiger has been charged with
manslaughter but some demonstrators want
her charged with murder do you think she
will get justice are you worried that
she won't that's my worry
Geiger's attorney declined our request
for comment but ultimately it'll be up
to a grand jury to decide if they'll
bump those charges up to murder there is
a rumor that the Jean family wants to
squash right now they say both them did
not know and did not have a relationship
with Geiger John
Omar thank you and thanks very help
Nkrumah but people are there's just
something that doesn't add up here and
that's why it's so confusing I think
it's good that Omar's saying the family
didn't know because you think they had
to have know they had to have had
something between the two of them but to
hear them say that it's very mysterious
because neighbors heard her say
allegedly opened the door opened the
door she says the door was open
neighbors say the door can't stay open
because it automatically closes so
you're right John a lot of things do not
add up there no more to come yes